i want to say two man shout out to a  sacramento legend who just passed dj geo  rip to him man  fella if you let me tell it one of them  real ones  uh big dog man  i'm saying i ain't really understand  what he meant to the whole city of  sacramento i understood what he meant to  me but i ain't understand what he meant  to the city of sacramento i mean you got  the people from the other side posting  them you know i'm saying you got  you know people who shouldn't be posting  and posting just do to the politics due  to the political affairs right people  who shouldn't be posting and posting  and uh  he was he  he was different he was different tweaky  full of confidence he was one of the  most  most confident individuals that i came  across  uh last conversation with him every  conversation with him was a flex he  flexing and uh  a loving forward i love him for it  yeah rest in peace man for sure